government programs benefit the poor at
the expense of the rich those are the
terms on which many public welfare
programs are sold but is that really the
case The Economist Milton Friedman
doesn't think so and called this the
Robin Hood myth
[Music]
Friedman argued that instead of taking
from the rich to help the poor most
welfare programs benefit the middle
class at the expense of the very poor
and the very rich this happens because
of a simple rule known as director's law
in a democratic system laws are passed
by 51 of the people voting One Way
against 49 of the people voting another
you might think the bottom 51 will pass
laws at the expense of the top 49 but
that's rarely the case
director's law implies that the bottom
51 percent tend to not only be less
fortunate but also less likely to have
the ability to organize themselves and
be politically successful
the top 51 are able to use their power
to control politics but they are by
definition also the most comfortable
with how things are and hence often the
last to seek political change the most
effective people in political activity
are running from the lower middle class
through the upper middle class
they are the people who are literate who
write the news who Envy the very rich
and who seek political change and what
kind of policies do they want welfare
programs for themselves
one famous policy that runs throughout
almost all Democratic societies is State
financed higher education it is sold on
the grounds of providing equal
opportunities to everybody to get an
education but what are the facts who is
really benefiting who are the people who
are attending public universities
it's usually people who come from the
middle and upper class families
occasionally there is someone from a
lower class family but that's a small
fraction children from middle and upper
class families often attend public
education for the longest periods
gaining new skills and building strong
networks that enable them to get higher
paying jobs
the taxpayers pay for it including
parents from the bottom of the income
distribution whose children are unlikely
to attend college and in the rare
instance that they do so often drop out
Friedman called State financed higher
education a program to impose taxes on
the people in watts to send the children
from Beverly Hills to college
what are your thoughts was Friedman
right and if so what's a good
alternative to help create equal
opportunities in a democracy
share your thoughts in the comments
below and read the description for more
information about Friedman and our work
thank you
one learning platform we really like
because it allows you to practice what
we preach learning by doing is
brilliant.org
brilliant has thousands of lessons
ranging from everyday maths to
Scientific thinking and data science
to learn data science for example you
select the level of maths you are
comfortable with and start with your
first lesson on probability
you'll learn to calculate the odds of
making a sale given a specific set of
conditions
or calculate the chance that a
particular group had seen the same two
films
to try this lesson and everything else
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org Sprouts or
click on the link in the description the
first 200 of you will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
brought to you with the support of
brilliant.org
to learn more check one of our other
videos to support our work and change
education join us on patreon.com sprouts
or read more about us in the description